give the agent the go-ahead miss james
okay sam we've trained for the situation
and you know what to do
mission's a go
we've been breached
[Music]
a talking ape i prefer chimp
[Music]
this is the earliest known photo of
daniel hall is attempting to build some
sort of new weapon
he must be stopped have an idea we
are going to take over well oh attacking
is that part of the plan i didn't know
that
is attacking part of the plan to take
over the world clearly you're new to
this whole evil thing
when humanity faces its greatest threat
it's imperative we have that data a
careful partner
one hero sam that's disgusting
you'll swing into action
maintaining an appropriate level of
physical training is important
please this is a serious mission
yes don't leave me hanging i should be
running this operation
me thank you you're one mysterious
monkey
donate the player hate the game
my dad right madeleine keates sophia
olanji
skip schweink do that where are you
going nevermind i don't care take this
back to the lab
saving the world is all
monkey business
who was that funky monkey
[Music]
cie
you